tonight you use impressive dribbling
skills to successfully fake out your
opponents multiple times
and in the second quarter you made a
jump shot where your body was turned
like 180 degrees away from the basket it
was just an amazing shot you're always
making these spectacular moves with just
within a split second do you anticipate
doing them or is it just a second nature
to you like do you just not even have to
think about it
um you know the way you explain it you
need to be around more often I I I you
know I just try to go out and do the
best with the best way I can to try to
you know find ways to better make make
some shots and make the right play